[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly libertarian podcast from the
magazine that's been scaring you about
government Force
since 1968 I am not Welsh joined by the
golf clapping Nick Gillespie Peter
suderman plays for today I'm Nick
gulespie for one last playlist I think
we can all call you nick
interruptcy uh from now on uh and a
triumphantly returning a Catherine
mangyu Ward happy Halloween everyone
howdy Halloween happy Halloween hey Matt
Catherine
before we start how is your new robot
leg my robot leg is great thank you for
asking and I gotta say the podcast
listeners really really came through
with the recommendations so thank you to
everybody but especially to the third
brag brother
who sent me an email oh yeah Austin and
Meredith the excellent Bragg brothers
who work for a reason have a third
brother he sent me a recommendation
um many many people sent them and I'm
grateful to you all but frankly the
third Bragg brother was the who is like
Alec Baldwin you know to Billy and Steve
he's the best I refuse to rank I refuse
to rank Bragg Brothers I love them all
equally and I'm grateful to them all are
you going to uh drop that recommendation
later on in the what you're consuming in
the cultural sphere I very well mind
okay uh so I won't tease it out all
right let's talk about the news that
Catherine has not been paying any
attention to a lot to do my best guys
can we go to her just to tell us what
happened yeah good idea a lot has
happened in the last 72 hours during her
uh narcotic coma uh we have Lefty
populist Luis Lula beat out righty
populist Dr Bill scenario I pronounce
both those names perfectly for the
presidency in Brazil Iran's
revolutionary guards have killed well
over a hundred uh protesters and ongoing
demonstrations their uh Bay Area
waccaloon got into the house of speaker
Nancy Pelosi fractured her husband's
skull with a hammer
and perhaps coloring our experience of
all of those events Elon Musk finally
took over Twitter and immediately began
acting just as erratically maybe even
more than pretty much everyone expected
uh Nick is trying so hard he's like I I
need to interrupt I need to uh let's
start with the latter bit of news since
it's been the subject of feverish
speculation for several months now
including on this podcast and now it's
finally here Elon Musk fired most of
Twitter's Senior Management announced
plans to lay off a quarter of Staff
change the home page welcome back
several accounts that had been suspended
or banned but not the big one yet and
try to reassure advertisers that the
social media platform won't become a
free-for-all hellscape his words uh
floated trial balloons about charging
people to keep their verified blue check
mark accounts and otherwise has just
Elon Musk all over the place
um Catherine you have two choices that
I'm going to offer you one is to Simply
to comment on how your the South African
boy pal has uh has acted now that he's
finally gotten a charge or
um now that you are just waiting your
broken knee back into it uh dude after
not looking at Twitter for a while
um has ever is Twitter even less
important and than you ever thought
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna go with the
latter which is that I did take some
time off of Twitter my brain capacity
was to like substantially reduced in the
last week and so uh Twitter was the
first thing to go and that was not at
all the wrong choice
um I I do think that the absolutely
insane series of events that have
occurred as musk has taken over might be
clarifying
um obviously everyone's just gonna be
screaming at the top of their voices for
a few days here but when things settle
down I do think the idea of you know the
very very murky concept of the Shadow
band which has preoccupied much of the
American right or at least the sort of
punditocracy of the right will that
we'll have some clarity around that um
because I think that so much actually
hinges on this idea that somehow
people's content is being suppressed for
ideological reasons and Twitter won't
tell us why or where for or how and at
some point with Elon in charge it does
seem like that case will be weakened
um and when it is
you know will people just come up with
new and more elaborate conspiracy
theories definitely yes but the audience
for them will shrink and so I am looking
forward to that
um I will not be paying for my blue
check if it comes down to it will you be
paying for reason staffers blue checks
Catherine that's the question I mean
yeah honestly Never Say Never I suppose
but um but yeah I personally will not be
selling out 20 bucks yeah no it's not
gonna happen was it uh was it 20 bucks
forever or I thought I read it was 20
bucks I think it was supposed to be a
recurring Revenue stream I mean the Elon
Musk has a good point which is like
Twitter doesn't make any sense as a
business I mean this was always the best
case for Elon buying Twitter was like he
actually isn't you know he's like not a
crazy person when it comes to figuring
out how to build businesses that
eventually succeed and Twitter is not
was not being run in a reasonable way
and I think that was you know as a you
as a clearly as a regular user of
Twitter I think he looked at it and was
like this could be done better you know
I'm I am always sympathetic to the uh
the plight of the uh the entj which is
that someone else is in charge and
they're doing it wrong is like that's
hell that's a hellscape so uh I think he
just said like what if what if I could
do it better Peter building on that and
I know I'm not supposed to talk about
the reason slack channels on the podcast
but I think he tried to coin a new uh
ENT what I don't know what Catherine
just said that's too many uh letters in
my long coveted brain but uh you like
there's some not in my social media
backyard thing talking about people's uh
approach towards uh towards social media
platforms can you elaborate please yeah
I think a lot of the griping by people
who are mad about Elon Musk taking over
Twitter is uh effectively equivalent to
nimby's griping about people building
stuff in their neighborhoods right it's
it's not not in my backyard it's not on
my social network right it's not on my
internet these people are nimbies who
are mad that a developer came in and
bought something and wants to build
something there and they don't like what
it is that they think that that person
is going to build even though that
person has not yet announced specific
plans much less started the dig out
right like to build this thing and so
they are gonna try and get the
government involved or try to get
whatever other forces that the community
is going to come together to save the
lot that somebody bought and wants to
put houses in
it's the same thing except what does the
what does the bulldozer what does the
figurative bulldozer look like I I think
I think it looks I think it looks like
Elon musk's boring machine which is a
literal like underground bulldozer thing
it's actually kind of awesome look I I
just don't I I cannot get worked up
about this at all I think it's fine it's
kind of funny I I can't really see a
downside here I do think it's clear that
Elon Musk is gonna lie on Twitter
because he says he's going to prevent it
from becoming a hellscape it's already a
hellscape
I mean about the already part nick uh I
think I think often about
one of your
um uh observations over time and I think
you're making this back and when
Microsoft is being challenged for
antitrust that basically by the time
people start to get excited and angry
and wanting to get Regulators on a
business or and or when that business
itself is out there trying to write
those regulations that's a good sign
that it's already on it's decline
there's a bunch of uh stories
recently of that like Twitter's super
users the people who drive most of his
traffic and engagements have been
fleeing the platform like droves is this
uh yeah they're going to Mammoth right
or something yeah we're you and I won't
know what the name of that is so we're
not too old for that cyber space
which is the hot new social media
Network which if I it's I can't I think
gas is the one where you have to give
people a compliment every day but it
might be the one where you have to take
a selfie each day which I think is kind
of like they're the opposite right like
that's the yin and the Yang yeah either
way it is obviously like the most
Sinister thing on the planet right uh
there's this to you all just sort of a
indication of that especially now we're
like you know Facebook and meta has
declined so precipitously that it's no
longer like in uh you know uh it's not
even fun to beat up anymore yeah right
you know I think they're bringing back
the Mafia the Avatar's got the legs they
got legs yeah they got legs you know
what we got legs here like most of us
baby and so like why would we go
somewhere else to have worse legs than
we have
um now I Matt uh to me the the best part
of all of this was and you were kind of
indicating this is that everybody hated
Twitter before Elon Musk took it over
but now it's really bad right yeah you
know and and just over the past 48 Hours
it descended into such a cesspool you
know a La Brea Tar Pits of terribleness
that people are like I'm done I'm done
I'm done I who knows I I mean I think
Catherine is right Peter is right like
we we have no idea what this is going to
shake out but you know the idea that
like he you know you buy a company that
for a decade has been floundering and
that everybody hates and that we
recently had some minor growth in
Aboriginal users but you come in and you
fire the people who are running it what
a monster
you know like why couldn't he work with
the team there and he's going to fire a
thousand useless Engineers
um and the reports I read from the Verge
which were attacking Elon Musk it was
all like it was people who hadn't had
anything to do with anything related to
the operation of Twitter for like the
past six to nine months so it's like
what oh my God like you know thank you
you know they're are they going to get
the news at like you know the massage
parlors on site that they've been
hanging out in for the past year I you
know this is all uh ridiculous I'm I
suspect that the the real Fallout is
going to be much more mundane than we
think that it's gonna Twitter is going
to be roughly similar to what it always
has been and you know without getting
too tried about it it's because the
problem ultimately I mean there are
better and worse ways to run it but the
problem with Twitter is the people who
use it which is everybody in this
conversation and other places so until
you either clarify
um you know whatever are the
expectations and what are the
limitations of expression in in a
transparent way it's going to be
basically the same old same old speaking
of the problem of Twitter is the people
who use it Elon Musk now who's the king
of Twitter over the weekend tweeted and
then later deleted a post linking to a
fabulous conspiracy theory website um
speculating that the real story behind
the hammer attack last week on Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul uh was some kind
of uh weird gay sex club hookup kind of
thing
um here's what we know about the actual
incident as of Monday morning 42 year
old Bay Area Sketcher named David D
papar D Pape somehow entered the Pelosi
compound late Friday reportedly shouted
where is Nancy
which was a refrain on January 6th
storming the capital and got into a
struggle with Paul Pelosi eventually uh
striking him with a hammer and
fracturing his skull Pelosi is expected
to have a full recovery the paper will
be charged uh probably on Tuesday he
appears to be uh quite delusional and
mentally ill he had a public blog of
sorts uh ranting about uh evil fairies
which I mean
they are uh Q Anon conspiracy theory I
mean they are thanks Arthur
I mean that one codes very right way
right it's this that's that was a big
part of uh Newt gingrich's contract with
America
if I recall
listen
the fairy problem is it's a
pre-christian
uh pre-iron age uh situation I don't
want to get into it right now but
fairies have always been an issue
uh anyways
um are we now talking about the Bronze
Age pervert or something I have no idea
Tinkerbell it's a uh it's pretty Tinker
Bell pretty it's pretty Tinkerbell
anyways um as happens in these cases I
think a hundred percent of the time uh
the attack was uh quickly and
immediately uh blamed on a toxic culture
and violent rhetoric uh uh coming
specifically from pro-trump
conservatives
um some of whom then uh promptly played
uh down to their own stereotype by
immediately concocting conspiracy
theories or tying it with Democratic
crime policies or in the case of Larry
Elder making bad jokes about Paul Pelosi
high five Larry way to go uh anyways uh
Catherine David from uh he uh wrote a
piece um in which basically making the
argument that both parties suffer
political violence but only one
celebrates it is that a a a way of is
that a takeaway from this case I don't
think so it's certainly not my takeaway
I mean I I I have a major case of both
sidesism and I I'm just gonna own to
that like I really do think that there
are very very very few pathologies that
are owned by one party or the other and
um you know when you look at polling the
sort of alarming number of people who
increasingly say that the other party is
so bad that um they are justified in
Breaking Norms or doing violence uh if
say an election doesn't come out their
way you do see that a little bit a
little bit more among people who
identify as Republicans but both sides
there it is both sidesism
um both sides there's been a real uptick
in that so I think you know the Baseline
of is one party getting crazy violent
and the other party is just trying to
keep order and be the good guys is a is
a false picture of what's going on in
our politics that said I also think
stuff like a person breaking into
someone's house and smashing someone's
head with a hammer is not a political
Bellwether it's a crazy person it's a
crazy person and we say this when we
talk about school shootings and we say
this when we talk about other kind of
outlier acts of violence I do think they
are outliers you know Jake Tapper was
this is not an outlier this is a trend I
I continue to disagree these are these
are shocking rare instances of violence
I do think there is a cultural climate
that is changing but I don't think that
you can blame
or should blame
a broad ideology I think you can say
um for instance about January 6th that
Donald Trump specifically increased the
likelihood that that would happen with
his rhetoric I think that is that is a
valid connection to make but I think
something like this attack on Paul
Pelosi which was absolutely horrible
um I just don't think connecting it to
broader Trends is generally Fair
um I think attention to it is happening
because of broader Trends I think we are
all very head up about it because of
broader Trends but but I just don't I
don't think it's fair to say I you know
in either direction I also don't think
it's fair to say oh but you know bad
policing policy is something I mean
that's like a crazy thing to say
um I uh some months ago was out to
dinner on the Georgetown Waterfront I
think I mentioned it on this podcast and
there was a group of people protesting
outside of Nancy Pelosi's house
um you know her her condo in Georgetown
uh they were Lefty protesters right they
were mad about Medicare for all and they
were mad about uh Paul Pelosi's DUI and
a few other things there were like 10 of
them they shouted for a minute and they
went away
um that's still the norm in America
that's how we typically behave and this
is a tragic unusual not to be broadly
extrapolated from outlier Peter is there
a a flip side of that maybe okay let's
say that let's not blame the specific
ideology on this uh attack but is there
something to be said about uh a culture
that is just too angry about politics
period that it like it creates a
free-floating energy source that a crazy
person can tap into when every election
is the most important of our life's
Lifetime and democracy itself might die
in a week
well well that's worrying I'm I'm
concerned now uh I do think that you can
criticize the escalation of political
rhetoric and sort of and and some of the
the apocalypticism of it I think a lot
of it is um
just doesn't fit the the facts it's uh
it's just wildly exaggerates the actual
threats that out there that are out
there which is not to say that there are
no threats out there or nothing worth
talking about
um or nothing to be uh scared about I I
guess I don't entirely both sides uh
this issue in in the way that say
Catherine does just because I think
January 6th is legitimately different
than other stuff because it was a very
clear active kind of
um politically motivated mob violence
rather than uh then an instance of uh
you know
of Violence by someone who by a single
person who is clearly somewhat unwell
which is what is true in this case if
you want to blame Republican ideology in
this case or sort of conservative
ideology cons you know right wing
um you know internet uh political
culture then I think you also have to
blame left-wing internet political
culture for the guy who shot up the
Congressional baseball game aiming at uh
you know at at a bunch of Republicans
right that guy wrote stuff online like
Trump is a traitor Trump has destroyed
our democracy it's time to destroy Trump
and co uh you know above the his repost
of a change.org petition right he was he
belonged to a Facebook group called
terminate the Republican Party another
one called the road to hell is paved
with Republicans that sort of thing now
I don't think that the Democratic party
or liberal ideology is responsible for
him shooting up that that baseball game
I want to be clear that's not a position
I hold but I think it's very difficult
to say that one is that in one case you
know it's responsible in another and in
the other case it isn't and so my my
feeling on these sort of individual acts
of violence is that they have individual
idiosyncratic idiosyncratic causes that
are deeply personal often because the
person is themselves quite unwell and
that seems to be pretty clear here this
person did not become unwell or deranged
because of online conspiracy theories
even though he trafficked in in them and
was uh and like posted a bunch of Q Anon
stuff that was crazy and is you know
sort of coded to the right wig he was
already deranged and because he was
deranged he glommed on to right-wing
conspiracy theories as well as the Fairy
stuff and was he was also a pro nudity
activist at one point I mean that's talk
about crazy uh Nick is there a media
double standard in all of this
um if so is it important or how
important and also what do we do do with
it I think that there is there is a
quickness and an interest in always
teasing out the dark you know red roots
of any kind of political violence done
by an insane person uh including like we
know nothing about this guy I think you
know other than that he is certifiable
right
um and that's from the people who know
him and his previous writings and then
these actions and things like that
um there's no reason to believe that he
is you know I've read one account by a
highly regarded kind of progressive
journalist who said There is a direct
line you know between this action and
Donald Trump and January 6. and like
that's just crazy I mean that's stupid
and I think a lot Matt you uh let our
coverage on uh was it Gerard or Jerome
lochner the guy who shot Gabby Giffords
Jared
um and you know that is kind of he is
the archetypal crazy person who commits
heinous acts of political violence and
there's nothing that you can tease out
of that that is going to comfort people
who want to wrap all of this up in an
ideological message to blame the other
side
um you know it is craziness pure and
simple and that's the best that you can
do about that and I think trying to look
beyond that is terrible where there are
and so like to the kind of people in the
media who reliably tip liberal and then
are using this to explain this is why
Donald Trump is bad and also all
Republicans should lose in the midterms
or moving in that direction it's just
stupid and risible
um on the same uh you know in in the
same way uh Republicans are
conservatives who find this funny and
like are making a bunch Paul Pelosi
jokes and things like that that is so
[ __ ] up and contemptible that shows
that this is why I've always hated
politics because it brings this out in
people in a way that is not even a
general kind of punkified response to
the insanity of the world in general but
like when it gets targeted in an
ideological it's just creepy and
Despicable so in that sense there's
blame to go around but we shouldn't be
looking at these things as indicators of
much of anything else when you get to
that question of pull it is political
violence rising in both the head of the
Republican National Committee said
political violence was Rising a bunch of
people on on in the Democratic party
said it was
uh you know it would be good to have
discussions I mean because that is you
know that is a a difficult I mean if
that's true we should be dealing with it
how do we Define that what do we mean by
that and you know is it I've read
accounts that attacks on Planned
Parenthood and other abortion clinics
have been going up since the Dobbs
decision I've also read on the right
that uh tax on pregnancy centers and on
anti-abortion protesters have increased
hate crimes went up for the first half
of this year less than they did the year
before hate crimes are subject to a lot
of kind of social construction and
contagion Theory where they they you
know reports jack up less because of
anything that's actually happening and
more because of you know whatever is in
the is in the media but those are
serious questions and I don't I don't
really know how you you kind of um you
know take the temperature of that much
less this much vager idea of political
violence against actual politicians yeah
I think there's also you know when you
think about the other unfortunately the
other most prominent attack on an
individual it's it's the Salman Rushdie
attack and you know I think my even my
brain that's already sort of resistant
to thinking of everything as politics
you know I I want to try and fit that
into a pattern you know if you're
looking for a pattern where everything
is political violence where every
individual attack where every kind of
prominent act of violence somehow is you
know on one side or the other of a scale
of whose fault it is
um you can really you can really
immediately just start layering on stuff
that's you know the the rusty thing is
politics in the very very broadest sense
but it's also you know wherever that
came from and wherever this Paul Pelosi
attack came from Strike me as very
different places
um and I or the Steve scalise
remember Rand Paul's broken ribs I mean
you know there's there's this which was
a laugh Riot for detractors
people love joking about that and he was
really hurt by I mean like physically
but also I you know I think
our our desire to put everything on one
side or the other of a ledger and to
somehow in the end say look the
Republicans are worse
um you know that's that to me is like
it's a terrible way to approach this
question and um and it seems to be a
very very powerful one to judge by all
the coverage of this attack
if I may there are kind of adjacent
issues which are not you know
necessarily about violence but uh
there's a recent poll ad talking about
uh you know Republicans believing that
Biden did not win the election you know
fairly Etc and it's like two to one
Republicans say that Biden did not win
uh fair and square and it's about
reverse on the Democratic side and the
Democrats are actually saying that they
believe in elections
um and it's deeply troubling to me that
so many Republicans self-identified
actually you know have to say to
themselves that Joe Biden did not win
the presidential election of 2020.
um and it's not violence per se but it
is a kind of way station somewhere down
the road to unreality that it's very
disturbing and I'm one of the things
that I'm most worried about is that I
you know and I I think I've shared with
a bunch of people this uh fundraising
thing that Hillary Clinton is doing
where she's talking about out how you
know Republicans have a plan to steal
the 2024 presidential election she's
part of a uh just raising money for a
group called indivisible which is has a
crushed the coup campaign because they
know that 2024 is going to be a coup and
it's kind of like
this yeah this is all like it it's it's
good it's a good sign if like most
Democrats are like no that's obviously
insane yeah but um but that could be
just a sign that they hold power right
now so they they like elections loses
again but there is something bizarre of
you know like that two-thirds of
Republicans are like no Biden didn't win
and we don't trust the elections yeah
it's like you're with you're going to
win the midterm elections and if you're
not going to believe them
I don't you know what the hell is going
on yes that's deeply and it's not a both
cider thing at this point um I think uh
one thing to say about political
violence if uh I mean you hear a lot of
um of
what about us might not be the right
word or might be the perfect word but
anyways in moments like this a lot of
people on the right will say what about
antifa what about the guy who was just
convicted of of Murder By running
through the parade in Wisconsin
um uh that in a case of you know killed
six people not many people talk about if
you dis in if in moments like this you
were pointing those things out
um and that's perfectly fine and and
correct to point those things out please
do not in the same breath uh make jokes
about Paul Pelosi or about Rand Paul or
about anything like that the
normalization of political violence is
uh smoothed by um uh laughing at the
victims of political violence um Let Let
The Comedians do it they're good at it
but as a like a general individual
comportment level [ __ ] ain't funny sorry
to cuss out there Fred young okay uh
we're gonna get to our listener email of
the week here in a moment but first a
word from our sponsor better help
friends
when you're weary feeling small
depressed by the ever shrinking days
overwhelmed by all that life is throwing
at you do you focus more on the problem
or on the solution stressful situations
often produce fight or flight reactions
but that's no way to get through every
day
in life we need instead to train our
brains into becoming problem solving
machines that's where betterhelp.com
comes in betterhelp is customizable
online therapy super convenient and
affordable and ready right now to set
you up the professional counselor to
help organize your Noggin to become an
organ that assists rather than a system
that overloads here's what you do go to
betterhelp.com Roundtable fill out a
brief questionnaire match up with a
licensed therapist and you'll already
get 10 off your first month if you don't
like your first match you can get
another
and so on and so on that's
betterhelp.com
Roundtable go there today you'll be glad
you did all right reminder to email your
queries to Roundtable at reason.com this
one comes from Jay Pinkerton who writes
I was pretty horrified by the twenty
five hundred dollar fines that PayPal
was handing out they retracted them sure
but it was no accident they targeted a
few of my favorite websites I consider
myself libertarian leaning and agree
with you guys on a host of issues but I
always get confused when you defend
PayPal as not being a monopoly I mean
forget about a dictionary definition and
just think in terms of utility what
viable Alternatives do I have in the
digital marketplace right now let's say
I'm horrified by what they're doing and
want to vote with my dollars because I
really really do what service should I
use instead venmo I think they're also
owned by PayPal Catherine
I think that the the question of what is
a monopoly is so interesting because
in law it has become unmoored from any
kind of
like coherent definition and so people's
understanding has also gotten blurry
around the edges
um the case that I always think about
um that sort of comes to mind about this
is the Whole Foods mergers
um many many years ago John Mackey the
uh now
um departed uh uh founder co-founder and
CEO of Whole Foods who is a friend of
Reason spoke with us about this many
times over the years but there's there
was repeat there were repeatedly
allegations that Whole Foods was somehow
monopolizing
some market and therefore shouldn't be
allowed to acquire like other schmancy
grocery store chains
um and I always thought that was just
like such a good example of how confused
people's thinking is about monopolies
because of course even if Whole Foods
did somehow monopolize a sub-category of
grocery stores you can always go to
Safeway you can always go to the
farmer's market like getting groceries
is the category not
organic grocery stores or schmancy
grocery stores or whatever and the
desire to kind of winnow down these
categories until there is a monopoly I
think is driven by a desire in general
to enforce
um anti-monopoly law so in the case of
PayPal
also thinks that it was a very much the
wrong decision for PayPal to impose
these mines they shouldn't have written
them into the terms of service in the
first place absolutely absurd all around
venmo is owned by PayPal
but there are many Alternatives when the
category is paying people which I think
is the relevant category right
um so that includes like the dumb thing
that my bank is always trying to get me
to use Zell
um which I don't understand at all uh
cash app actual cash credit card
payments uh there's you know bartering
like I don't know it just seems to me
that there are really
um it is almost always the correct move
to look very very broadly at the
category before you declare a monopoly
not only because I want to Stave off
legal action against perceived
monopolies but also because that
reflects the reality if I want to pay
somebody and I think PayPal is behaving
badly I have other ways to pay people
and if I choose to use PayPal anyway
it's because I think
the things they've done that are bad are
outweighed by the convenience that it
provides and that's a legitimate
consumer decision as well where do we
like find a what Marketplace only
accepts PayPal so I've only used PayPal
or at least almost exclusively used
PayPal to buy things through eBay
historically but uh just like I I'm
looking at the most recent eBay auction
that I won this weekend for uh
for an old printing of Stanley klisby's
historic cocktail book New Orleans
drinks at Famous New Orleans drinks and
how to mix them I paid
15.95 plus shipping for it I'm just
looking at the listing and not only do
they accept Paypal they also accept a
bunch of major credit cards but also
Google pay and I didn't even use any of
those things I did this entirely on my
phone and used Apple pay which is
connected to uh to a credit card and so
I completely circumvented PayPal not
even because I had problems with PayPal
but just because the easiest way to pay
for things on my phone is Apple pay
connected to a credit card card that as
far as I know is not owned by PayPal and
so it just doesn't seem to me like
there's any major marketplace where the
only payment option is Paypal it might
be that there are some marketplaces
where PayPal is more convenient
but I'm not I'm struggling to think of
like where is it that you could that
like the only thing they accept is
PayPal
yeah just to check the one place that I
used to use PayPal uh which is obviously
baseball reference
um to uh to do various things there and
uh and that to uh pay for the Dave
dravecki and Eric show
commemorative John Birch Society you
know I think they'll even they don't
even uh uh allow people to uh to
advertise on pages but they allowed some
of us uh grandfathered people so I I
will say though that after the story
came out about the fines
um I moved my money out of venmo that I
just sort of like had some money kind of
sitting in the venmo account because I
did not want to uh to be sort of
to be involved in that service any more
than is necessary uh Before Peter
interrupted me I was going to say that
um the uh they used to only take PayPal
for the advertising and things like that
which is the only reason why I started
PayPal to begin with I'm pretty sure and
now they accept Opera in fact I've been
paying with uh credit cards or debit
cards uh ever since Nick do you have
some thoughts about the Monopoly uh well
you know one is Paypal was co-founded by
you know a certain Sinister South
african-born Refugee billionaire right
so you know I think that's all we need
to say about it but uh to Catherine's
point it's uh really fascinating the one
one of the mergers between Whole Foods
and I think it was whole oats which was
another you know kind of Boutique
organic food uh store the FTC actually
developed a new definition of a market
so it was literally not organic grocery
stores it was like fancy schman
absolutely organic grocery stores
because Walmart sells you know by a
factor of like Six Trillion more organic
produce than anybody else in the country
so it can't be Organics because then
Whole Foods wouldn't have a monopoly Etc
and you know there's a lot of a lot of
wisdom in understanding that and again
not going to that idea of like when you
start thinking about you know antitrust
actions like PayPal has so many
competitors now I've always found it
incredibly useful and very reliable
payment processor so there are I have I
have it on my phone and and various
other places and there's lots of times
where for whatever reason a credit card
or another payment system doesn't work
in the moment and I use PayPal so it
still has a utility I think another
question like so you don't need
antitrust to get around PayPal because
as everybody's pointed out that's
already happening and that's really
great there is a an interesting question
of when these kind of back-end services
start saying we are going to become
moral middlemen as opposed to merely you
know Financial middlemen
and we're going to start setting the
terms of like whether or not it is legal
for you to buy what might be sex work or
this book or that thing
um you know it's within their right to
do that and it's within the right of
customers increasingly to do two things
one is to exit and go elsewhere and the
other is to [ __ ] and moan and get them
to change their policy which seem to
have worked here so I think it's all
good actually this is one of those rare
instances where I think uh you know a
lot of a lot of smoke a lot of heat and
we're better off after this it teaches
us a lot of things about how markets but
you also think in the background is the
threat of Regulation and I think that
that's really something that it's it's
important for us to keep pointing out
like yes these are private companies yes
they're making decisions we may or may
not like but how many of these decisions
are Guided by a fear that they will
eventually be forced to do something
similar or that they will be held liable
in new and creative ways for purchases
that were made using their platform
um there there's always always a
background of kind of politicians or
Bureau properties that want to that may
potentially want to make this a thing I
think that that is a big piece of
um the major credit card companies
getting literally gun shy I think that
there is um and so I you know I always
want to be careful to balance private
companies can do what they want with our
private companies doing what they want
or are they scared of the government
because I do stuff because I'm scared of
the government sometimes that's not
exactly what I want
um and and I believe they do you pay
your taxes because you're scared I just
finished my 2021 taxes guys please clap
wow hold on uh uh I would also
you know want to stress that these
companies can be coerced and co-opted by
government one of the most chilling acts
I think by any
um uh you know Rich free world
government uh over the last several
years was uh the government of Pierre
Trudeau freezing people's I think it was
venmoa certainly all kinds of uh uh just
whatever they're all named Pierre back
again it's just come on uh a little
fathed guy a froze people's accounts to
protesters
um effectively uh overnight they leaned
on them they invoked an emergencies act
um uh it became even people who were um
uh trading uh Bitcoin uh uh were were
cracked down upon and just because they
decided that it was an emergency that
there was a bunch of truckers uh
protesting covet policies
um that's chilling that's a blueprint
for bad things to happen in the future I
think I hope that that couldn't happen
in America because the Fourth Amendment
protections but those protections have
been systematically eroded by the drug
war and other things uh especially when
it comes to financial transactions for a
long time and we just Goose the IRS by
87 billion dollars so we live in a a
hellscape is what I'm trying to say all
right speaking of maybe we can escape to
Twitter uh that's the problem if this is
a hellscape let's go where the air is
clean uh it's Halloween people uh let's
do a little Lightning Run Catherine you
have terrifying fingers even in your
debased wheelchair bound condition we've
used those fingers to illustrate uh how
we can slash governments before
government slashes us let us go and talk
about one thing
about politics and government that
scares you the most Catherine you start
I am
see for me Matt I just really you know I
I've not been a hypocrisy gal in the
past you know I think that's usually not
the best gotcha the best gotcha when
politicians do something dumb isn't you
said the opposite thing before the best
gotcha is that is bad for the Republic
don't do it because it's bad but uh of
late specifically with regard to the
legitimacy validity whatever of our
elections uh I am looking ahead to no
matter who wins the other side is going
to say that the elections were
um poorly conducted rigged
um whatever and and both sides will be
equally likely to do it they will do it
in a way that is equally poisonous and I
find the hypocrisy of that excruciating
that is the thing that makes me scared
the next election makes me scared not
because of
um
you know some particular mechanic that I
think is going on although there are
individual developments in like state
election boards and things like that
that are bad but because I don't I don't
think any of that matters I think what
matters is whoever wins the other side
is going to lose their shiz I really
believe that and uh and I hate it
Peter what scares you the most and you
bonus points for using the Congressional
mode War
pretty scary
uh the the death
CBO report on nuclear Wars humans
or even like 35 of them that'd be pretty
terrifying I think the thing that is
under discussed that's maybe not my the
thing that is that I'm actually most
frightened of uh but that I think people
need to be a little bit more worried
about is um Joe Biden's student loan
forgiveness plan is illegal
legal he illegally spent a half trillion
dollars and that is very bad on its own
but that's going to set a precedent that
is going to be used again because it
turns out to be quite difficult to mount
a legal challenge against this since for
under the legal definition uh of uh of
harm no one is harmed by this no
specific person can claim harm or it's
very difficult to find somebody who can
claim specific harms uh from this and
because of that it's difficult to find
somebody who has standing to Sue and so
if Joe Biden gets away with this and
there are reports as of this morning
that the checks are good or the the you
know the the I don't know if it's checks
but it's gonna you know the balance
changes are gonna clear within two weeks
or something if Joe Biden gets away with
this this sort of thing will be done
again in some different way that we that
I cannot predict this morning but it
will be bad and it will just sort of
become the new normal in a way that I I
am just not excited about so long as we
don't have nuclear war in case if we
have nuclear war I probably I'll be less
worried at that point Nick what is
scaring you about politics and
government right now uh you know right
now is uh gridlock or the idea that
gridlock is good or is good enough uh
which comes up a lot uh we're about to
have a divided government because the
Republicans are clearly going to win the
house they may take the Senate and
there's a lot of people and this is a
real uh reliable libertarian uh kind of
go-to to say well you know gridlock is
good it used to be more effective in
actually restraining government spending
but so much of government spending is on
autopilot now that more and more is
going into what are considered mandatory
uh outlays entitlement spending in
particular uh interest on the debt
things like that and it's gone now where
it's starting to approach three quarters
of government spending and
um that is it terrifies me that we have
gotten to a point now where most of our
hardest foot budge [ __ ] battles or
spending battles are really symbolic
because the real spending is elsewhere
and we are content to go along with that
to go along with a kind of symbolic
activity uh that's the equivalent of you
know marching in a gay prop gay pride
parade or a Fourth of July parade or
something we have to turn back to what
is actually driving massive amounts of
federal spending uh
um waste Fraud and Abuse gonna get it
someday over the weekend there was a
well I'm actually kind of glad that
we've given up even talking about that
you know because that's always a lie you
know that we'll we'll claw back the
overspending of this stuff so there was
a clip over the weekend
um that was widely shared and high-fived
by so many uh journalists and
commentators Bill Crystal was one of
them but it was mostly uh left of center
types although Bill these days is
certainly oh he's practically working
for the commentary uh but it was of uh
Barack Obama giving a speech in uh
Wisconsin I believe it was just growling
uh about how the Republicans are coming
after your Social Security and
everyone's like yeah hi you know we need
more of this on the on the uh on the
campaign uh stump and uh this isn't
necessarily my you know what scares me
the most but uh it's a it's a sign of
how absolutely debased
um not just politics but the coverage
and processing of politics so many
journalists
um let alone the the crystal lights were
uh were super excited about this when
Obama
13 years ago right before he became
president you know told the Washington
Post we can't continue kicking the can
down the road on Social Security on my
watch we're gonna have to fix this
because everybody realizes that this is
a slow-motion disaster in the making and
to see a guy go from there to 13 years
later absolutely demagoguing in a way
that's not even at all realistic about
where the Republican party is at when it
comes to this issue and then to see
everyone just high-fiving
um and themselves engaging in the
forgetting of that
um uh that's a that's a sign of where we
are I guess my big fear is that with all
of the populisms on the left and the
right um which gets worse and Stephanie
Slade writes about it wonderfully before
the magazine I'll read everything she
writes
um that uh at some point someone's going
to be clever enough to use the ability
to conduct pretty much total
surveillance on everything we do
um that is a the story that kind of like
excited everybody in 2013 and 2014 with
the Edward Snowden Revelations how much
the NSA can do how much there's just
every digital thing every phone uh
conversation uh it's the government has
the ability to tap into and we've kind
of just forgotten about it
um it's still there uh and it's still
waiting to be actualized by someone who
cares and that's going to be a a dark
moment or a dark possibility lurking
around as we get into a much more
punitive idea about what politics is for
which is basically lock her up and lock
him up and lock you people up this is
why we need an analog Revolution you
know and I don't just mean two Vamps
though I do actually I mostly mean tube
amps but also like moleskin notebooks no
you're not wrong pen and paper no uh
own your own your media but you're gonna
have to uh uh build some storage space
um all right let's get to our end of uh
a podcast what we have been consuming
Peter
rereading two William Gibson novels the
peripheral and agency those are his two
most recent novels they are Set uh in
near Futures and in one case sort of in
a kind of alternate presence as well as
in a further future after an event he
calls the jackpot
the jackpot is a really interesting
concept
um I I'm gonna spoil it just a little
bit here but it's basically that
Humanity had all the things happen all
the all the apocalypses just happened at
once so like climate change and nuclear
war and like the Meltdown of democracy
and social order and like hunger and
starvation and just like and
so in some ways it's sort of it's
horrific and apocalyptic but he also is
like well you know we sort of there's
still people and there's still new
technology after this and yeah it's kind
of not great that like the world is run
by like weird Russian kleptocratic
family gangs but on the other hand
things seem basically safe and stable
and people learn from the jackpot um and
then they go back in time or sort of
back in time to uh to offshoots of the
timeline that are not actually in their
past but are like sort of branches of a
of their past that no longer affect them
directly and they mess with global
Affairs and technology and it's it's
just a the novels are both
very like just very engaging to read in
the way that that Gibson's work always
is uh he's just super smart about how
technology works but he's really smart
about how technology affects culture and
there's like in in the peripheral which
is now an Amazon TV show in particular
he takes us into a near future world in
which in which like today's sort of like
high tech or tomorrow's high tech has
kind of filtered down to the lower
classes and there's like guys living in
trailers who have like who are like all
these sort of drones just like sitting
around on their property and the way
that like now people have their you know
motorcycles and their half-built cars
and that sort of thing and it's it's
just it's really fascinating and fun to
read and um and I even though I like his
politics are very left and he's like
he's he's just much more interesting
than any than almost anybody else who is
speculating about you know the next 100
or a couple of hundred years of human
existence and uh and how it might turn
out so that's uh two William Gibson
novels the Prof referral and agency Nick
what have you been consuming
uh I've been reading uh David Hackett
Fisher the historian's latest book
African Founders it came out earlier
this year African Founders how enslaved
people expanded American ideals and this
is a history of Black Americans
essentially uh from uh the the moment
that they showed up as slaves uh and
actually even I guess a little bit
before that through about the Civil War
but before uh you know before they were
freed and he looks at the the ways in
which slavery developed in different
sections of the country uh you know so
there's the Deep South uh there's the
Mid-Atlantic region there's New England
Etc and he traces
um basically the way that they acted and
how that fit in with and changed or
challenged kind of the way we think
about America it's a fantastic book it
is so rich and thick and deep in history
that it just changes the way way you
would think about colonial America as
well as early Republican America and
um I you know it's it's kind of reading
through it it's kind of an answer to the
1619 project which obviously had a bunch
of historical questions uh you know or
uh you know about its interpretation and
it never turns its eye away from the
idea that slavery was fundamentally sick
and you know and was uh both imposed and
maintained by brutal physical violence
against blacks both free and enslaved
but it broadens the way that uh you know
what it meant to be black in America
from the very beginning and it is
exactly the type of history that we
should be uh kind of celebrating and
engaging in because it's just it's thick
it's Rich it's unexpected it is filled
with both Triumph and undescribable like
um uh you know tragedy so highly highly
recommend African Founders how enslaved
people EX banded American ideals David
Hackett Fisher is just one of the best
kind of uh generalist historians of the
American Experience people probably know
Albion seed or Washington's Crossing by
him this is this is just like the book
everybody should be talking about in
this particular about all right uh
Catherine what did you think besides
drugs
uh definitely a bunch of drugs
um but uh of the many many
recommendations again thank you from our
listeners
um the uh Alex Bragg recommendation of
the show this is going to hurt uh is the
one that has stuck with me I uh
absolutely made the choice to watch a
sort of chaotic medical drama
immediately before going into surgery
and it was weirdly the right one
um this is a it it's sort of
um
dark scrubs I guess
um
but it's Set uh in the NHS it's a it's a
BBC show
um and it's about uh centers around a
doctor who works in an obstetrics unit
um everything is a mess everything is
bad all the time
for this uh for this doctor in a way
that um feels very realistic uh you know
there's sort of like not enough clean
scrubs in the machine after he works a
double shift type thing uh there is no
element of house in here right like
there's no like we have to figure it out
and it's not lupus it's a rare
um you know African parasite it's just
kind of the regular stuff of medicine
and
um and the ways that it can go wrong the
fact that it is set against the
background of the NHS is really
interesting because it um it means that
you don't have the easy crutch that a
lot of American Medical dramas take of
you know the insurance company won't let
the baby have a heart transplant right
like there's none of that
um and it shows that actually kind of
scarcity and
um and in particular you know the at
least the way that it's filmed the
facilities that that he is working in
that they are working in are kind of
like they're crappy they're like
government issue linoleum crappy in a
way that um feels very uh feels very
real
um I really enjoyed watching a bunch of
doctors panic and have blood spread all
over them right before going into
surgery I think because it provided a
contrast to what I what I assume my
experience was like no one was like
hungover and um and full of Despair
while they were operating on my knee or
at least it didn't show so
um I recommend this show
uh whether or not you are about to be
cut open by a doctor this is going to
hurt uh it's uh I guess it's an AMC show
I think that means you can get it on
Hulu and some other places I uh watched
it on
um Amazon Prime
so I so your knee-jerk reaction was that
it was good I hate you and I hope you
die on the operating table yeah
um
pretty specific uh I speaking of people
you hope to die in the operating table I
watched a five-part documentary series
on the Lincoln project uh it's called
the Lincoln project why did you do that
uh well because you know it could be any
number of people uh that I'm referring
to here
um this is a Showtime documentary
um the fifth and final episode errors uh
this week on November 4th um I think
it's this week uh and so you haven't
seen the end of it yet thank you um for
questioning my Integrity but yes I have
Nick because the miracle of streaming
services are such that you can watch it
even before it's uh of last official uh
broadcast time I would I know I was in
challenge I was just so you know how I
do know how it ends and uh and that will
make uh your heart one's heart uh swell
with even more hate than the rest of it
does so the Lincoln project for those of
you you who are kind of like don't
remember exactly it was founded in 2019
uh by a bunch of uh kind of never
Trumper Republican political Hitmen and
strategist Steve Schmidt
um who was the campaign manager of the
John McCain campaign in 2008 Rick Wilson
you might recognize
um he's the guy who wrote I think
everything Trump touches dies and all
these guys became these sort of
Republican pugnacious MSNBC commentators
uh there's also Jennifer horn who at
some point was the bill weld campaign
manager when he was running against
Donald Trump a bunch of other people uh
besides and so it was it's directed by
uh Kareem Amber and Fisher Stevens who
were like Hollywood lefties of done
documentaries uh Fisher Stevens is also
an actor and so they got access they
were fascinating being having hated
Trump and they came across these
characters Stuart Stevens is another one
um well for the Lincoln project who like
oh how are these Republicans like doing
doing these great kind of uh like Trump
tweaking ads that make Trump mad
um they put up a billboard of uh Ivanka
and uh uh and uh Jared Kushner on on
Times Square
um uh and to to make them uh super angry
um so they went and they got embedded uh
with them as in the final months of the
2020 presidential election basically
Lincoln project would you know run an ad
uh in usually in in Washington DC on Fox
on Hannity knowing that Trump would see
them to try to provoke a reaction this
would then go viral online and everyone
would just mash the Donate button they
would use that money to make more ads
and also to attempt to influence of the
voting in Arizona and Georgia and some
other places including seven Senate
races in which they lost all seven you
uh uh I this will scare you straight
from from the politics from Passion from
hating Trump from loving Trump they show
a lot of of documentary footage of
January 6th and like the worst excesses
of trumpism which serve is kind of like
a it wakes you up through the fog that
you had had tried to put behind you if
you sit and watch through the whole
thing
um but the great part about the
documentary is that so they get this
access it's the last two months they're
all decamping to Park City Utah to kind
of all sit in the same office together
and it goes through the drama of the
election and everything like that and
then just before uh it uh the election
itself happens the organization itself
just starts to implode so spectacularly
and you have all these guys the
sympathetic cameras there to watch all
of it happen John Weaver one of the
co-founders uh is uh seen to have uh uh
sexually uh groomed and harassed a whole
series of interns and people knew about
it they lied about knowing about it it
is uh it is a disgusting documentary
really uh it's well enough done that you
can take away a bunch of different
things there's an interview with Fisher
Stevens last week I'm going to write
about it pretty soon uh in which he says
yeah you know I'm just hoping that this
really motivates people to vote in the
midterms
um uh and presumably like against Maga
candidates and it like motivates me to
never pay attention to politics for the
rest of my life which would be hard
given my job uh it's just gross it is
absolutely grotesque people uh doing
grotesque things and making themselves
rich and then backbiting and turning on
one another and freezing people out and
talking crap
um Steve Schmidt is a a monster of a
human being I wish him uh all the worst
possible that could happen to a person
legally uh to happen so uh check it out
if you have a taste for such things
um again it's well enough done that it
can support your own Illusions including
being really you know psyched about
these troglodytes getting themselves
Rich by tweaking Donald Trump if that's
what you like
um but uh yeah Nick the the final
episode the final five minutes of it uh
uh to see uh how they go through all of
these uh Horrors and then can still
raise money at a Beverly Hills
fundraiser afterwards it's uh it's it's
special it is so special did it make you
want to go start your own firm that's
called like something strategies
it's amazing uh and it's it actually
like it it shows how uh this economy
Works
um and the guys will just basically
admit I mean they they had a uh
companies within the company they raised
100 million dollars for 2020. they kept
calling themselves the most uh
successful Super PAC in history
um that individuals within like Reed
Galen has a company called Africa
whatever strategies uh that spent 27
million dollars of that and no one knows
what it was on
did they have any uh measurable success
in blunting they say because you
mentioned like the seven Senate races
that they all lost and obviously most of
them are connected to major loser
campaigns in the past like so they had
the most sympathetic character in this
is a guy and uh and I should say I know
a lot of the people who are uh profile
in the documentary which made it kind of
weird to watch too uh but Mike Madrid in
California long time Republican on
California he was part of a political
team and they were focused on like micro
targeted ads it wasn't the trolling
stuff uh that stuff it was a bit trolley
but in Arizona in Georgia and Arizona
and Georgia went to Joe Biden uh and so
they can tell themselves the story that
they helped make that happen
um and also the main story that they
tell themselves is that they distracted
Trump so much that he didn't do the
things necessary to win re-election
that's the big one they tell themselves
I think there's
um you know that that's a story
um it's not uh something that people
who've looked at it very closely tend to
corroborate but um that's how they do it
but uh does it still exist it does or
did it it does uh Steve Schmidt left it
I just saw uh yesterday uh in a tweet uh
that in which Steve Schmidt was calling
uh JD Vance a fascist
um uh that he's starting some new thing
uh and pocketing all the money from uh
you know getting a lefty money that
hates JD Vance style fascism but the
Lincoln project uh exists on Rick Wilson
and Reed Galen are still out there and
still uh and they made the shift after
January 6th to be uh and after all of
their scandals and implosions and and uh
and uh you know lawsuit settlements and
things like that they're now shifting to
be pro-democracy they're doing the
pro-democracy work it is that's like
turning uh the March of Dimes going
we're anti-birth effects that one it is
you got a that's a permanent employment
approach but anyways sorry to uh to go
on at length about it
um but uh wow people uh politics is I
had written a piece called why the
something like why the political grift
won't stop a month or so ago and I kind
of wish I'd seen this um it's it it's
the conversion of your political hatreds
into bad people getting rich and not
otherwise really impacting politics one
way or the other
um is something that we should all learn
from and maybe stop throwing money at
your hatred that's the end of the sermon
okay thanks for listening everyone go to
all of our podcasts including there is
an interview with Nick lesbian Nick do
you have something to advertise an
upcoming show or something like that
oh yeah this uh Thursday in New York
City uh if you go to Eventbrite and
Google reason speakies you're just go to
reason.com events I'm going to be doing
a live interview with Stephen Heller who
is a fixture in art direction of
alternative and mainstream Publications
for the past 50 years uh it's he's a
fascinating Fighter for free speech in a
time when punks like him would be thrown
in jail for uh working on things like
screw magazine uh Al goldstein's mag
where alternative press is in the late
60s and early 70s he has a great Memoir
out go to reason.com events and check it
out boom go to all of our podcast
reading.com podcast and if you like what
we do as an organization please consider
giving a tax
free deductible whatever uh donation uh
we're not uh Steve Schmidt um but go
toreach.com donate uh
we don't use that money to build a park
of City Mansions I swear to God okay see
you next week
[Music]